hello everyone welcome to this session
on monitor and troubleshoot your network
infrastructure with data driven insights
this is lakshmi sharma director product
management for networking with my
colleague id nevers girls product
manager working on a lot of these
products that you will hear about today
in this 20 minutes talk we are going to
discuss the common user journeys during
migration
troubleshooting and optimization of your
network we will also demonstrate how
network intelligence center the product
that provides you tools and capabilities
to support these user journeys is
helping you by data insights and
offering a platform that would be used
in most effective ways throughout your
user journeys of infrastructure
specifically networking troubleshooting
migration and optimization
network intelligence center is a way of
offering you aiml powered net ops
acceleration platform
this is cloud ai ops in real working for
your workloads onto gcp our goal is to
become the simplest cloud to operate on
through an intelligent cell driving
network that extends beyond gcp to
hybrid two multi-cloud two branches two
two prices and capabilities that you
have built for operating into virtual
and cloud journeys and also integrating
all the way to legacy infrastructure and
services that you built on-prem or any
location here henceforth i mentioned
leveraging all the ai and the data
insights that we continue to build for
building gcp and making gcp the platform
driven by intelligent insight and
self-driving cloud so network
intelligence center is google cloud's
way of delivering on to that vision of
self-driving network
it contains multiple modules to ensure
you can deploy
what you have intended to basically it
gives you tools to for your deployment
to be matched to your intent
it offers you troubleshooting any any
kind of performance and connectivity
issues as you're migrating or as you're
operating on to gcp with whichever
location whichever place and whichever
application you have been running
currently or you have been building
towards
it helps you optimize your network
including
firewalls and other network services and
infrastructure services that you will be
using to deploy your workloads onto gcp
networking is the foundation for all
cloud deployments and business processes
we expect it to be up and performing
well our customers expect it to be they
want networking networking to be
seamless regardless of the use case and
the journey that we are working towards
user journeys throughout cloud based on
our experiences of customers migrating
and working on gcp with us
specifically networking scenarios there
are three main categories
planning and migration
day to offset scale
and optimization so these are the three
sets of categories and use user journeys
that we will be taking you through and
how different modules in network
intelligence center help you build and
drive towards that
here is what you need in each of those
two stages each of those stages
early stages deployment is live so when
you're migrating your network or your
workloads while your deployment is live
what you want to make sure is that what
you intended to what kind of
architecture you deployed for is what
you are getting when you have migrating
or when you are migrating and then you
also once you have measured
configuration and your intent and your
topology then you know when you want to
make sure that your traffic is flowing
as you intended to so that's kind of
number one
in the early stages uh user journey
during planning and migration the next
step would be that yes i have migrated
yes i have it is intended configuration
and traffic as intended as expected to
be now the second second phase is that
is it production ready is the production
line so that that's the time when you
want to make sure that your network
continues to stay healthy you are able
to identify and troubleshoot issues in
advance
a priority not at the time when the
issue happens but prior to when the
issue has happened or in cases issue has
happened you being able to troubleshoot
it and identify the root cause for each
of those issues in operation or during
production
uh production operations very fast and
be able to remediate
as an extern
we also want to be able to optimize
your deployment you want to be able to
optimize your deployments that you're
running by having the control on
performance and cost first you want to
be making sure that your your
applications are running with the
performance and reliability no matter
what kind of optimization that you make
the configuration optimization path
optimization and services optimal
mission will be architecting it again so
we give you tools so that you can
optimize it back and then you can go
back and check your intent again your
traffic paths again and you're back to a
very healthy operation cycle
so for all of these user journeys that
we talked through
you need a lot of data to be available
you want your data to be continuously
monitored for you you want a control on
where my data is where my logs are where
my alerts are you want all of that
information across all your deployments
across these stages and you want the
data monitoring and telemetry everything
to be available to you so that so that
you start to make decision in a
self-driving and self-sustainable manner
without really any interactions to be
honest like literally zero interaction
with uh people on other side of the
cloud
so for all of these data how do we bring
this data to you network intelligence
center provides that visibility into
working on this network
how the deployment actually looks how
and where the traffic flows and are
there if there are any problems
and issues
with configurations or the traffic or
the routing any kinds of paths or any
anomalies or any sub-optimalities that
you see
so once we have all this information for
you the next step for is for us to
provide users the tools to make that
data easily available and have the
system intelligently and then auto
magically and automatically address any
existing issues as well as surface the
user the most important things the most
relevant insights
we do want to avoid the noise technique
and after all the network is a business
enabler we want your focus to be on the
most important and relevant information
it allows everything else to communicate
network allows you to communicate with
your users network allows you to
communicate with your business processes
and your business people
you want the network to auto resolve
problems where they are relevant and to
surface the user any issues that
requires intervention
that is why we are working on enhancing
eifs capability
across different services and
capabilities that we have in networking
to deliver the most important
information to our users across all
these journeys that you've heard in a
timely and concise manner so we want to
be going from a place where you're
planning migrating writing your
architecture you're making sure that
your intent is right then you're
automating and optimizing towards for
your performance and reliability and
costing once you have delivered the
cycle once we want the ai ops to be
working with you so that you are able to
deliver and you want these capabilities
to be delivered in a self-driving
self-contained manner team
so day two ops
uh day to ops capability which you see
in the middle are what we are focusing
in now and you will see some
capabilities in planning and migration
stage and day to op's case so that you
are able to
leverage our products and capabilities
today while we take bring you on to the
journey of eventual optimization and
self-driving capabilities
okay thank you lakshmi so basically when
we do listen to the users they emphasize
the following thing
we want the network to be up and running
it needs to be available and it needs to
be performing and we have a business to
run we don't need to deal with anything
else and essentially it needs to be up
and running if it breaks we want to know
as soon as possible now this needs to
happen
regardless of what's happening with our
traffic it can be spiky it can be
in a nice way to say it it can be
dynamically changing
and
in those conditions we need to be able
to monitor the network
and essentially
that's what the users have been saying
the network intelligence center have
been uh giving them and i think the best
example or the best quote that i got
from this from one of our users
was listen we're used to aggressively
monitoring everything on-prem now you
take our most precious workloads and you
put it on this um magical mystery black
box and we don't want to lose visibility
we cannot afford to lose visibility and
i really connected really that really
resonated with me
maybe with the tiny exception of
not wanting to bring snpp to the cloud
unless i really have to but with the
exception of that i i really believe in
that as much data as possible and as
much visibility as possible
now let's uh jump right in and take a
look and take a look at the modules of
the network intelligence center and how
they're used in the user journeys that
lakshmi has described
the first place where
users typically start
is network topology
basically they come here when
you've just migrated something or you've
created something from scratch now
there's a new thing and want to make
sure that whatever it is that you've
built
that it matches your intent
are those the servers that i wanted to
have are they communicating in the way
that i expected how is traffic following
how is it flowing
are
these relevant regions being served from
relevant continents
do i have any inter-regional
communication that i'm not supposed to
have am i bypassing load balancers when
i shouldn't be all those things are
basically things that you see in network
topology with the addition of being able
to see performance metrics
on the edges now from here
if you're trying to get more information
there is actually a direct pivot
from network topology into vpc flow logs
so if you're looking at a specific
server at a specific edge and you want
to get you know more
swiss knife kind of information
you can just go directly from here into
vpc flow logs in the relevant context
and see what's happening now in network
topology you can see compute instances
load balancers connections to on-prem
cloud apis
we are going to add gke infrastructure
support
and that's that's essentially topology
typically used in migration or where
something changes
now the next thing is the performance
dashboard uh this is where you end up
when things are not going quite as
expected usually when you say there is a
problem or you suspect a problem you'll
go here and here you can actually see
packet loss and latency metrics
for traffic in your projects there is a
combination here
of
synthetic traffic and sampling of actual
user traffic
of your machines you will see here only
zones regions where you are deployed and
you can essentially see your own
specific performance
now one thing that we have recently
launched is the global performance
dashboard
in many cases
when there is a problem and you get to
the performance dashboards the question
you're going to ask yourself is okay
something is not going as expected i'm
seeing high latency or i'm seeing high
pocket loss
and it was for that matter
is the problem anywhere in my deployment
or is it a google cloud-wide kind of
problem
and having those two performance
dashboards side by side basically lets
you compare your project performance to
the performance of all of google and
then you can know whether there is a
network outage or maybe there is just
a few servers choking somewhere 100 cpu
and that is the reason why they're not
properly responding to requests
any
google-wide outages are going to be very
clearly visible on both dashboards and
obviously when you pivot from per
project to this one you'll be able to
see that
where is the source of that problem
now as i said we are going from
relatively high level okay i just
migrated please tell me in high level
how everything looks because i'm trying
to understand the connection between
things and from there you can actually
drill down to very specific metrics as i
said
it really actually depends
on the type of user okay some users
they're going to listen just throw all
the information you can i'm going to
derive all the insights myself just give
me all the data possibly i'm just going
to plug it into a third-party system or
i'm going to process it and
i want to see raw data
and other types of users are just going
to say please crunch everything for me
and please only call me if it's super
critical super important and you're
absolutely sure that this requires my
attention now for the kind of users who
want to see everything and want to get
this
visibility they're in cloud monitoring
they're very specific product metrics
you can see for example for every vpn in
every project
you can see the state of the vpn tunnel
are there any issues you can see whether
the tunnel is up or not have there been
any handshake problems what's the
throughput for interconnects as well you
can see the status of the attachment you
can see the throughput you can see the
throughput over a period of time
essentially you can go from very kind of
a high level this is your topology to
very very specific details and i think
this is the goal of really providing
something
that we can
proudly call data driven right okay
here's all the data
and you can crunch it yourself or we can
crunch it for you and get to a point
another this is actually one of the
favorite products by our users saving a
huge amount of support calls and it goes
like this
give me endpoint a keep b and point b
and this product checks
whether the configuration
allows connectivity between these two
endpoints
this means essentially if you're looking
at vm to vm node to master vm to cloud
sql on-prem to cloud sql is your
configuration actually allowing this
connectivity and then if it's not
allowing this connectivity if
basically this module is going to tell
you there is a firewall rule blocking it
or you have a routing issue
now these look at configuration and what
you we have just recently launched is
dynamic connectivity tests which for
quite a few of these scenarios they also
look at what's actually happening on the
data plane okay so your configuration
allows connectivity
now let's look at deeper
let's take a deeper dive and look at the
metrics
what is the latency between these two
what is the packet loss ratio if any
between these two you have the
connectivity test to basically tell you
whether any two end points
are able to or should be able to per
configuration and are actually able to
connect and talk to each other and how
that connection looks like now network
intelligence center has additional
modules like firewall insights for
example that's going to tell you whether
you have unused firewall rules
or any additional information so there's
quite a lot there that you can go and
actually check out
in um in a quick recap in this not very
long presentation we've talked about
what we have seen to be the typical user
journeys
when users are migrating when they're
actually operating at very large scales
and when they're trying to do
optimization
and
now since this is a recorded session and
um
i want to share with you some of the
questions that we are usually being
asked
and the answer to this
probably the most common question i get
is what about gke
and the answer is that yes
essentially the performance dashboards
show the performance for cheeky
workloads as well
we have gke connectivity in connectivity
test as i mentioned in topology we are
working on showing the gke
infrastructure
that is a big part of the workloads that
are running on google cloud and that's
definitely something to be covered we're
also looking at
serverless for example not just gke
again the same support you have topology
you have connectivity tests so there is
quite a lot
that you can learn this is definitely
not just for uh
compute
another super common question especially
by the larger organizations
is
how does this fit into my existing
processes because i am hybrid because
i'm multi-cloud because i already set up
a thing and i want to continue using
that thing which which makes a lot of
sense
so basically we're looking at it from
two aspects one aspect is taking all the
information in the network intelligence
center and making it available to be
consumed programmatically so you can
grab it via api you can plug it into
your own systems you can trigger any
sort of response based on alerts for
example which moves that and so on and
so on the other one is that the
combination of network intelligence
center and cloud monitoring basically
allows you to see
all your monitoring
in a single place
last question as i see we are
approaching time is can this be used for
compliance
and that's actually one of the major
goals of the network intelligence center
you can see where traffic is flowing or
for high purposes you can see where
traffic is not flowing you can get vpc
vlogs audit trail you can get
screenshots that you can then use in
compliance reports so there is actually
quite a lot in mind in terms of
compliance
and quite a lot that the network
intelligence center can deliver
um this team is always available for any
additional questions that you may have
there is also quite a lot happening in
the next 21 networking sessions and i do
encourage you to go ahead and take a
look thank you